our
Albert all right listen listen okay
okay hello
how are you it's October 20th 2022. I am
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV subscribe if you have not and
uh that cold open there that is AOC
giving a little talk in her home
district and uh the protesters continue
to show up they don't like her very much
they think she's one of the key pieces
leading us to this Bizarro war in
Ukraine they've had it with cutting off
kids genitals they don't like her
General disposition and uh she gave them
exactly what they were eBay
her reign of terror is almost over I'm
telling you she's got a chance to lose
this election she really does we can get
rid of these people and what do I always
tell you guys the post-woke world to get
in it it's not we have to just map what
it would look like to really be beyond
all of these people and just say turn
the clock back 10 years ago and all feel
good about America again and have some
liberals have some conservatives
battling out but we're all like okay
America's good let's roll and then we'd
be looking in the rear view mirror going
AO see you later we don't want anything
to do with you people so today we're
going to talk about that wide tent
conservatism or libertarianism uh the
sort of stuff that I've been kind of
pushing around here and we're also going
to talk about the the last ditch effort
by the Dems to hang on to power because
all of the polls every bit of sort of
cultural norm right now is sort of
trending towards the conservatives the
Republicans winning again you know my
feelings on the word conservative I'm
using it in a broad events but there's a
lot of good momentum right now we are
going to dive into it using video tape
and before we get to any of that let me
talk to you about nugenics real quick do
you want more energy to counter the
negative effects of Aging Eugenics total
t-testosterone booster with testofin
will help you turn back the clock
re-energize your workouts and get you
better results at the gym and help you
look and feel like the man you really
want to be Nugenix total T contains man
boosting ingredients like testifin it
has been validated in five clinical
studies shown to boost free testosterone
levels in men because nugenics total T
boosts free testosterone that stops the
aging process or at least slows it down
you'll feel stronger leaner with more
energy and drive and more passion too
your partner will notice the difference
while every product professes quality
many other products use generic
ingredients that are often far less than
clinical grade with nugenics total T you
get the same clinical potency levels
used in the trials and new Eugenics
formulation is backed by 10 years of
science and research Eugenics total T is
the number one selling testosterone
booster at GNC you can get a
complementary bottle of nugenics Total
Tea when you text Reuben to two three
one two three one text now and get a
bottle of nugenics thermo their most
powerful fat incinerator ever with key
ingredients to help you get back into
shape absolutely free that's texting
Reuben 231-231 text Ruben 231-231 and
now back to me okay so with this sort of
realignment
that I've been talking about with the
same liberals waking up realizing if
you'd like to save liberalism if you'd
like to save americanism if you'd like
to save anything with any semblance of
the country that we once had that we are
on the precipice of giving away uh you
may have to vote for Republicans this
time around it's something I've
obviously been pushing for quite some
time but now there seems to be a bigger
Trend in the country towards that uh
Tulsi gabbard who of course was a
Democrat congresswoman from Hawaii ran
for president got called of Russian
operative by Hillary Clinton the whole
machine tried to distort destroy her
finally she left the Democrat Party as
you guys know about a week ago she has
not said she is a republican nor do I
think that that is a key part of this
but she has said she left the Democrat
Party that is the signal for now and now
she's out there campaigning with
Republicans so it doesn't really matter
if she just puts the r right next to her
name the proof is in the pudding or at
least with who you're sitting next to on
stage and she did an event in Arizona uh
with Carrie Lake who of course is
running for governor take a look
the True Believer that if MLK Reverend
Martin Luther King Jr were alive today
if JFK were live today if our founding
fathers were alive today they would be
America First Republicans I really
believe that
okay so that was obviously Carrie
speaking there the fact that Tulsi was
even on stage with her that Tulsa said
hey not only am I leaving the Democrat
Party but I'm going to be on stay on
stage campaigning with someone that has
thought as a far-right trump supporting
blah blah blah
now I want to get to the content really
of what Carrie Lake just said right
there what would say MLK and JFK uh what
party would they affiliate with today
would they affiliate with the endless
state that wants to get us to war the
endless state that wants to tax you to
the bejesus the endless political party
that uh wants your boys to be girls and
to usher in racism and all of those
things I suspect not now it might be a
bit she might be taking a little bit of
poetic license to say that MLK would be
an America First Republican but I
certainly think it's very fair to say
that JFK absolutely and MLK to some
degree would be leaning towards
conservatism or republicanism at this
point you may have seen a little bit of
this speech from Dr Martin Luther King
Jr from about 40 50 years ago and you
tell me does it sound more like
something a modern Democrat would say or
a Republican I have a dream
that one day
this nation will rise up
live out the true meaning of its Creed
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
[Applause]
I have a dream
my four little children
will one day live in a nation where they
will not be judged by the color of their
skin but by the content of their
character I have a dream
[Applause]
when we let it read from every village
and ever Hamlet from every state and
every city
we will be able to speed up that day
when all of God's children black men and
white men Jews and Gentiles Protestants
and Catholics will be able to join hands
and sing in the words of the old Negro
spiritual free at last free at last
thank God Almighty
you know what's beautiful about that and
we don't hear too much of it there
there's an unabashed love of America
there that sits underneath everything
he's saying he's saying we can get to
this place that is the promise of
America Martin Luther King for his
frustrations with America for his for
his desire to see the Civil Rights
Movement make sure and ensure that
everyone regardless of the color of
their skin or religion Etc would be
treated equally it wasn't because he
hated America that he was fighting for
that it was because he loved America it
was aspirational right he wanted America
to be the promise of America he wanted
America to live up to its own founding
to the Declaration of Independence to
the Constitution and all of those things
he did not reject all of those things
which is what modern Democrats basically
do right the 1619 project and we're an
evil patriarchy and all of the stuff
also he was so now if you're if let's go
back to my initial question before we
played the video so which party would he
more aligned with those ideas which
party were they more aligned with well
he's talking about all men being created
equal okay well that would be in stark
contrast uh to what the Democrats of
today want which is this idea of equity
where the system is going to rejigger
things to make people to make everyone
equal remember at the end right not
where we're starting but at the end
everyone will be equal we've played many
videos of Kamala Harris saying that over
and over and over of course the the
famous line that he did not want his
children to be judged by the color of
their skin but by the content of their
character that is completely the
antithesis of identity politics and
identity politics is the driving force
of today's Democrat Party it simply is
they it would be very hard for a
Democrat to get up there and say hey we
shouldn't be thinking about color people
we should just get over the color thing
and we're just gonna get out there and
you need a little luck and work hard and
some of it's on you that's not a
Democrat message is it and then at the
end and that we're all God's children
hey that's in essence you're here if
you're legally here doesn't matter if
you're Jew or Gentile black or white
blah blah blah if you're here and you're
a decent citizen you are one of God's
children you are you get every
opportunity to partake in this wonderful
experiment of freedom so I leave it up
to you to make the decision on that one
I think what uh you could probably glean
what I think about it but it said
whether you'd say he's an America First
Republican or JFK ask not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country right that it's on
you it's not that the government should
just give you that is he that was a
Democrat message when he said it back in
the 60s
not really Democrat message for today
actually it's the 180 reverse of it
today but let's contrast that message
Carrie Lakes comments okay these guys
would be demo would be Republicans what
are the Democrats now then we play the
MLK stuff kind of sounds like oh Freedom
America's good these are the basic ideas
that most of us are on board uh and then
you have the radicalism of today's
Democrat Party so I've talked a bunch
about Stacy Abrams over the last couple
days she was in an episode of Star Trek
she also lost a Georgia gubernatorial
race a couple years ago then contested
the election she repeatedly said that
the election was not legit and they
stole it from her and blah blah blah
well now she's continuing down that dark
path although she really upped it
yesterday this one might have this one
really I saw this video and I was like
even for these bananas crazy Democrats
this one's a bit much uh she thinks that
abortions if you have more abortions
that'll help inflation
for governor of Georgia
I would assume maybe incorrectly but
while abortion is an issue it nowhere
reaches the level of interest of Voters
in terms of the cost of gas
food bread milk things like that what
can a governor what could you do as
governor to alleviate the concerns of
Georgia voters about those livability
daily hourly issues that they're
confronted with but let's be clear
having children is why you're worried
about your price for gas it's why you're
concerned about how much food costs for
women this is not a reductive issue you
can't divorce being forced to carry an
unwanted pregnancy from the economic
realities of having a child
three lordy lordy I'll do it in a
Georgian accent my God that woman is
crazy
imagine I mean the gall of everything
she said right there in essence she's
saying don't have kids because you got
to spend a little cash on your kids that
is so vile and disgusting and again as
someone that has a nine week old and a
12 day old or so downstairs like the
idea that I would ever look at them and
be like yo thanks to you I can't have
that wagu tonight like what what and
that that the answer then would be ah
I'm pregnant I do kind of want some
stuff you know what I mean I really want
to get to Target and get some stuff you
know they've got all that uh what do you
what are people buying at Target these
days I got like chip and Joanna they
have all their little candles I want
some of those chip and Joanna candles I
gotta abort this kid it is so vile it is
so backwards when Martin Luther King Jr
talks about all of God's children where
is that Spirit within that woman my God
it's insane and by the way the
administration even knows this it's
insane because note noted black lesbian
press secretary Karin Jean-Pierre was
asked about it and well take a look one
more that folds in the president's top
domestic priorities in Georgia the
president's endorsed candidate for
governor Stacy Abrams is suggesting that
one made one way to mitigate the effects
of inflation is to get an abortion does
President Biden agree
I did not see her comments on this so I
don't know the context of this again I
want to be careful because this is a
political debate and it's related to a
midterm in election so I this is I'm not
going to comment on that
and she doesn't know she doesn't have a
TV the girl's never been on Twitter does
she have a phone she has no idea what's
happening and how could she possibly
comment on something that's happening in
the world of politics she can't get into
that it's not like she's the press
secretary for the White House I mean
what do you want her to do I mean she's
working very hard over there you think
those calls just show up naturally
that's Stephanie how long would it take
a woman to just get curls like that
or so she doesn't have time with the
curls to
you see what I'm saying people you see
what I'm saying but her her rhetoric I
mean that that thing about the abortions
and it's it's because women are forced
also no one's forcing you to have
children most people engage in sexual
activity voluntarily and both parties
should be uh responsible and make sure
they're doing what they got to do of
course that excludes rape but she's
obviously not talking about people who
get raped having abortions right like
it's you're just want some more stuff
and let me this kid is a financial drain
on me but they are completely out of
touch and I suspect they really know
they're about to get shellacked so they
better start making up some excuses now
so here is Stacey Abrams yesterday and
of course the early voting is happening
already in Georgia and she's laying the
groundwork laying the groundwork to
contest the results of the election
we are here today because we are about
to make history in 20 days we are
changing Georgia let's get it done
thank you all so much for being here
yesterday was amazing
and I'm not talking about the debate
that was good too
but yesterday we saw record turnout for
early voting
yes we should be excited but let's
remember what that means it does not
mean that voter suppression doesn't
exist that's like saying that there are
no more sharks in the water because more
people get in
we know that voter suppression is Alive
and Well in Georgia but we're stronger
we're faster and we're better than it
and we are going to bring it and we're
going to win this election
meaningless dribble that's what you've
got uh that's all she's got meaningless
triple so she's telling you right now
there is record turnout record early
voting turnout uh yeah that would imply
lady that there isn't voter suppression
now note and we watch the full video she
never points out who's being suppressed
it's a little odd you would think that
CNN or MSNBC or somebody would be in
Georgia right now and they'd be
interviewing people who were being
turned away from the polling stations or
elderly people who can't get there to
vote or people who are trying to put
their mail-in ballots together and get a
nasty paper cut and bleed out and then
the envelope is soaked in their own
blood and it never makes it to the thing
you see what I'm saying it's all
nonsense but what she's saying is
there's record people are voting but she
just wants you to know if I don't get
what I want at the end obviously some
Shenanigans uh CNN even covered the the
restrictive voting law that is going on
in Georgia that no one can figure out
while telling us that they're getting
record turnout it is the first major
election in Georgia under a restrictive
new voting law that's not stopping
record numbers of people from casting
their ballots early
I can see how people have brain damage
if you watch CNN too long right like if
you watch MSNBC you're just completely
insane and that's why I always call it
the televised mental institution but do
you get what they're doing on CNN on one
hand they're telling you there's record
turnout all sorts of people showing up
and voting nobody's being turned away
but now the restrictive voting laws I
think it includes something like having
an ID saying who you are that sort of
thing endless driveless nonsense but
that's corporate media running cover for
the Democrats so if the result isn't
what they want we'll roll into four
years of oh you are allowed to question
the results of the elections because we
got Republicans in charge and they
obviously are the bad guys so we better
question results of course uh here's a
tweet from Molly Hemingway who I met a
couple weeks ago at an event in Florida
she was talking about what's going on
here in Florida and she wrote
interesting answers from both Democrat
demings doesn't say whether oh sorry
interesting answers from both Democrat
demmings Val demings who's running here
in Florida for Senate against Marco
Rubio Democrat demings doesn't say
whether she will accept election results
Republican Rubio says he will accept
election results because of Florida's
great election laws so even think about
this here in Florida there is nobody I
have not heard and I'm I'm out there
okay I'm out there in Florida
I have not heard anyone saying we are
having any issues with voting we have an
extremely secure system DeSantis has has
done everything possible to make sure
that all of the people in Southwest
Florida will be able to vote despite all
the wreckage that they're still trying
to fix up from the hurricane like
there's no there is no uh feeling of oh
there's Shenanigans going on here in
Florida so Rubio is coming out coming
out right now and saying hey we're good
to go if I lose I lose if I win I win we
are good to go because I trust the
system demings who is not going to win
by the way but she can now they can just
seed the craziness with the Democrats
well I don't know she has no evidence no
reason to think there's someone send me
something someone if someone can find
some story somewhere about how Florida
is hiding votes and is stopping black
people from voting and all of the stuff
please I'll gladly cover it tomorrow
would you do that for me uh here's a
tweet from Jen Saki and of course you
remember Jan saki she was the Chief liar
at the White House White House Press
Secretary and she tweeted this out she's
now an MSNBC correspondent because when
you lie for a living in the government
the next thing you do is get a cushy
high-paying job at a corporate news
Outlet she wrote holy moly Sienna New
York Times poll more than a third of
independent voters and smaller but
noteworthy contingent of Democrats said
they were open to supporting candidates
who reject the legitimacy of the 2020
election as they focus on economic
issues well that's my God she must be
freaking out why would people how
bizarre that people might support
candidates who have talked about stolen
elections before well Glenn Greenwald
who is a lefty uh you know he's I would
say he's shifting a little bit maybe
he's a little bit say where I was a
couple years ago but certainly a lefty
no one is thinking this guy's a
republican right he had a thread about
some of the things that Democrats have
said because saki's freaking out oh my
God how could people vote for people who
would contest election he had a great
thread on people that support people who
contest elections uh here's a tweet from
Corinne Jean-Pierre back in uh you're
not going to believe this
2016. stolen emails stolen drone stolen
election welcome to the world of
unprecedented Trump yeah stolen election
she said it there herself you see it
stole an election she now works for the
White House I think we've uh we've got
some more right uh he continued in this
thread since I've been writing about
politics Democrats have been denying
election outcomes it was basically
Universal among liberals that bush
Cheney stole the 2000 election many
believe that about 2004 Ohio and Rove
two-thirds of Dems believed Russian
hackers converted Hillary voters to
Trump yeah that's true it continues one
of the most admired Democrats in the
country you guys know this one Stacy
Abrams refuses to concede her 2018 loss
in the Georgia gubernatorial race
insisting that she is the real winner
and that Republicans cheated to win the
media ignores this whole story when
using election deniers that really of
course is the point you guys also know
that Hillary Clinton tweeted out uh
during Donald Trump's presidency that he
was an illegitimate president and by
golly we've even got video I believe he
knows he's an illegitimate president he
knows he knows that there were a bunch
of different reasons why the election
turned out the way it did
like in retrospect now listening to that
and and that so many people bought into
it he knows he's illegitimate but there
were a bunch of reasons I don't have to
get into the reasons but there was a
whole freaking bunch of them you know it
was a lot of them what are we doing here
there's a lot of those reasons you know
all right so what's their last ditch
effort well they're realizing that
nobody trusts them on this war in
Ukraine everyone's had it with the woke
people aren't that thrilled about the
economy and gas prices so suddenly the
elderly man pretending to be President
Joseph R Biden he's releasing our
strategic petroleum Reserve now our
strategic petroleum Reserve has the word
Reserve in it and that means that it is
reserved for emergencies like if all
hell broke loose or there suddenly was
World War III or we had massive pipes
burst or a nuclear accident or a whole
series of crazy things happen then we
have our reserves so you don't want to
really be tapping into these things for
no reason uh but that's what we are
doing right now uh here is video of
televised mental institution MSNBC host
Chris Hayes saying uh why gas prices are
so high and you're not going to believe
it it has nothing to do with the
Democrats
oil companies OPEC Saudi is not exactly
eager to make sure prices are low before
an election where Democratic candidates
are vulnerable
it's also why Saudi Arabia might want to
suddenly announce a cut in oil
production right before the midterms of
course Democrats can't just throw their
hands up and say oh well
because
the future of American democracy is in
as we report night and night out on this
program real Peril existential Peril
people have complicated and busy lives
and they've got things they're thinking
about when they go to the polls like the
cost of living inflation and yes gas
prices the one price in America that is
posted on every street corner those
digits they are going to be front of
mine for voters
and so we find ourselves in a situation
where keeping gas prices low
is key to preserving and strengthening
the future of our democracy and so here
we are that's Biden releasing oil from
the reserves day
and all this speaks to what the future
of our lectures look like
alternative Universe man if you're
watching that show you are in an
alternative Universe from the one that I
exist in uh yes it has nothing to do
with the fact that everyone from this
Administration has been talking about
the green New Deal and destroying fossil
fuels ending fossil fuels as Joe Biden
has said on more than one occasion it
has nothing to do with not unleashing
American Energy we've got plenty of oil
of course we do they don't want to go to
it because they want as gay Pete said
they want you to get an electric car you
schmuck what are you doing with your
regular gas guzzler what do you mean you
can't afford a seventy thousand dollar
Tesla get moving out there do you even
work what are you doing people uh it's
of course complete nonsense that all of
our problems this is what they do with
everything all of our oil problems and
our gas problems and our energy problems
though that's on Saudi Arabia and that's
on OPEC right when we have other
problems related to all of this and
energy who is it it wasn't that it has
anything to do with that that was Russia
and Putin's price like it is sure I'm in
charge I'm Joe Biden I'm supposed to be
the leader of the country but it's
nothing to do with what I'm doing come
on guys I'm eating ice cream I'm out
there doing everything I can uh here's a
very odd response that Joe Biden gave
when he was asked whether releasing the
these reserves was a good idea why
responds to Republicans
like any of this spr release because to
help Democrats in the midterms where
have they been the last four months
that's my response
I think he genuinely means that where
have they been because he doesn't know
where he is so I'll Grant him that uh
virtually every Republican has been
screaming from the top of their lungs
about releasing American Energy and
going for our own stuff right that's
what every Republican has been talking
about let's be energy independent while
the Democrats have been the ones saying
no we must have to end fossil fuels it's
just ridiculous so the fact that now
Biden sees the numbers or whoever's in
charge about it they see the numbers
they see the bloodbath on the way so
what are they doing two weeks before the
election we're diving into the reserves
so we can artificially depress the cost
so a few people will be like that Joe
Biden is doing good gas went from six
dollars a gallon to 450. here's video of
Karin Jean-Pierre being asked about
these uh reserves and uh yeah she's not
very good at her job the president just
said that the oil releases from the
Strategic Wars are were not political
but we've seen on a daily basis that the
administration is making these
announcements on abortion gas prices EV
student debt and array of other programs
such as infrastructure
what's the goal of these announcements
given that they're happening so close to
midterms look and the president was
asked specifically that that question on
on the gas prices in our announcement
today and he was very clear he said if
you've watched in these last several
months these last four months I believe
that what is what he said he's been
working every day to lower gas prices
for the American people especially after
we saw Putin's brutal war in Ukraine
which led to Putin's price price hike as
we have seen in the last several several
months guys it's Putin's price hike it's
OPEC it's Saudi Arabia so we have to
empty our reserves and Joe Biden's been
working every day you have no idea how
hard this guy is working uh some of you
may remember the president before Joe
Biden his name was Donald Trump the
media didn't like him very much but we
had a booming economy and our Energy
prices were down and he was actually
refilling our strategic petroleum
reserves even though they were already
full because he wanted to make sure we'd
have way more than we need do you
remember this based on the price of oil
I've also instructed the Secretary of
Energy to purchase at a very good price
large quantities of crude oil for
storage in the U.S strategic Reserve
we're going to fill it right up to the
top
saving the American taxpayer billions
and billions of dollars helping our oil
industry and making us even further
toward that wonderful goal which we've
achieved which nobody thought was
possible of energy Independence
it puts us in a position that's very
strong and we're buying it at the right
price
land right getting energy at the right
price energy Independence not trying to
destroy fossil fuels
etc etc so we had competency now we have
this thing so again because people are
not stupid I know the Democrats and the
Machine want everybody to be stupid and
eating bugs and fat and not being able
to take care of themselves and just
begging for handouts but most people are
not stupid and that is why the polls are
bearing what they're bearing right now
because people are realizing enough with
this enough with this it again it does
not mean that the Republicans are great
but they're a hell of a lot better than
the Democrats so what will the
Republicans do if they take over well
Kevin McCarthy who I've had on the show
who's the Congressional minority leader
right now he stands to become the the
new Nancy Pelosi right he would be the
majority leader if the Republicans take
the house uh he was on CNBC uh talking
about what he would do on the very first
day they always say they're going to do
a lot on the first day I'm starting to
think they don't mean it all on that day
but let's Grant him that videotape so
Republicans uh have called the January 6
commission uh you know I people say
bipartisan with two Republicans you
quickly would discount that
um if you if Republicans take over is
there is there going to be the same kind
of thing for Hunter Biden I mean will
you do Americans want that to be looked
into to the same just you could say it's
the same thing as January 6th of what
Republicans say can you
well I'll tell you this we won't play
politics in this process we will follow
the law and we'll follow the information
wherever it takes us but first and
foremost we're going to focus on the
economy we're going to make sure that
America's economy is strong we're going
to tackle inflation we're going to make
us energy independent we're concerned
about the security and safety of America
we're going to secure our border we're
going to stop defunding the police and
fund them we're going to give a rating
scale to every single prosecutor to make
sure they're upholding the law we're
going to pass a parent's Bill of Rights
so the parents have a say in their kids
education and yes we're going to hold
America accountable but on that very
first day we're going to repeal 87 000
IRS agents government should be here to
help you not go after
okay so everything he said there is the
right stuff now I don't know that
they'll do it all on day one I know
they'll do it on on day 80 or day 120
and they will most likely not be as good
as we all want them to be that's part of
how this whole thing works but if
they're basically for funding the police
if they're basically for cutting taxes
if they're basically for tackling
inflation which would be related to
taxes if they're basically for helping
the economy energy Independence like if
they're basically heading in that
direction uh oh and then that thing that
he said right there at the end that how
about we get rid of those 87
000 new IRS agents remember that
happened in August when I was off the
grid they hired 87 000 new IRS agents to
go after basically everyday people and a
certain amount of them will be armed
like that was what the government
decided to spend money I mean the
government spends money on everything
they spend your money on everything but
the gall of these people in the midst of
everything that's going on here say also
we need 87 000 more bureaucrats to
figure out how to pill over and steal
more money from the citizens that's the
grift that's what we need we just need
more cash it just never ends so I think
hopefully if McCarthy becomes the
majority leader that he will he will
live up to what he just laid out there
and if they do some of that stuff you
don't have to do all of it right we
never get what we all want but if you
marginally if you can fix things on the
margins that may be all we need right
now right we we get the squad out of the
way we neuter President Biden we
basically have a country of Law and
Order and decency and some sane
direction that would be pretty pretty
good but it ain't going to be easy and
you know why it ain't going to be easy
because we still have all of these
organizations much like the CDC the
Center for Disease Control which has
lied to us about virtually everything
over the last couple years and you are
not going to believe this one here's a
tweet from Dr Chris Martinson uh
breaking the CDC panel voted 15 to zero
this is yesterday guys to add the covid
vaccinations to the vaccines for
children program tomorrow they vote to
move the childhood schedule I will never
forgive these people or their
institutions uh the video was posted
Zoom video of the 15 doctors all voting
yes on this to in effect recommend that
all children toddlers children get the
covid vaccine no no well new father here
no no no no no no no no no you will not
be injecting my kids with your toxic
evil [ __ ]
how about that uh you ain't gonna do it
uh these companies of course have
incredible they have immunity uh the
vaccine doesn't give you immunity but
the companies have immunity uh when it
comes to you suing them for side effects
and not uh you know going through with
what they promised and all that uh we'll
jump back to Carrie Lake who we started
with a little while ago Carrie Lake
again running for governor in Arizona uh
she saw this bit of information and
tweeted this out Arizona when I am
Governor the covid vax will never be
mandatory for children in Arizona you
have my word I actually believe her
Isn't it nice to say hey there's a
politician who I kind of believe I kind
of believe her she will not force that
stuff that experimental stuff that does
not stop covid that does not stop the
transmission of covid you get in covid
every which way you can figure it out
she's not going to force kids to have it
and those people I have no doubt that
those 15 people who all voted for it you
know they love diversity but the one
thing they hate is diversity of thought
there wasn't one person on that panel
who was like um
guys I don't want to be a dick about
this but after two years of the covid
vaccines basically not working and
fouchy getting coveted several times
after he's been boosted and the CEO of
Pfizer getting it a couple of times and
now we're realizing it never stopped
transmission and we didn't test it
properly and there is this whole thing
about young males now with my
myocarditis and a whole bunch of other
stuff it's like how about I'm going to
be the one descending vote but they
didn't get one
they did not get one dissenting vote
so what is the Republican platform after
things change and I think that they are
about to change but as I always say you
got to get out there and vote give the
devil is due don't think they won't pull
something blah blah blah what is the
Republican message uh well there's also
another gubernatorial uh race in South
Carolina uh that's happening in a couple
weeks and I haven't talked about it much
but here is Republican Nancy mace
responding to and then laying out what
her position is of what a republican
Administration would look like so every
woman in this District would like to
know why you don't care about our
children's safety in schools I'm a mom
of two kids I understand working mom to
say I don't care about kids that is
repulsive children
you know what is not safe is supporting
sex change surgery on kids that's not
safe supporting Representatives
a little bit later you can use this is
your rebuttal okay so that was obviously
mace in the green dress there and
basically you can see her opponent
basically being like you don't want kids
to be safe it's because she actually
believes in the Second Amendment right
so if you're for a gun somehow you don't
want kids to be safe it's a nonsensical
argument but that's really all they got
at the moment and then she calmly lays
into hey we're gonna have a border We're
not gonna have sex changes for kids the
basic stuff again we have the sanity
party and an insanity party pick one
people pick one but you know all this
gender stuff when she's talking about
you wouldn't want sex changes for kids
all of this gender stuff which has burst
forth into almost everywhere drag shows
for kids as I asked a couple weeks ago
why don't they have drag shows for
actuaries why is it that drag shows
always have to be for kids where are the
drag what you guys want to have a team
building workshop with a well of a drag
show I'll bring in a drag queen and
should you no no nobody was into that
wow okay I tried you know I'm trying I'm
trying uh but it was making me think you
know we keep pushing this this sex
change stuff on kids and they want kids
to read about sex and they want teachers
to talk about gender and they want
teachers to give students you know
opposite sex names and hide it from the
parents all this really banana stuff and
then I had a tweet yesterday that that
went pretty viral and I want everyone to
think about this work this one through
with me so this was in response to Chris
Ruffo Chris rufo had said it's not
anti-lgbtq or a book man to say that
this material is not appropriate for an
elementary school classroom parents have
the right to tell their local schools
that they do not want kids exposed to
graphic sex materials whatever the
orientation he was in the further in the
thread what he's talking about there is
there's a book that's making its way
around a lot of public schools right now
where they're literally teaching kids
how to have sex like things like how to
give a hand job I kid you not this is in
public schools so now flash to my tweet
on this everyone over 30 think back to
your third grade teacher now imagine she
talked about sex and called you another
name while hiding it from your parents
it's so ludicrous you can barely picture
it though Mrs kochenauer did read a
secret garden and do the voices herself
I love that woman I loved Mrs conchino
I'm sure she's long gone she was
probably in her I thought she was very I
remember thinking she was very old she
was probably in her 60s at the time
she's she's probably gone although when
I did tweet that out someone that I went
to high school with reached out to me
and said that my fifth grade teacher
Miss secunda is 90 something and she's
still cooking still doing well so Mr
kunda if you're watching I love you lady
but everyone just watching this for just
a moment and you guys in this room
picture your third who's your third
grade teacher do you remember her name
Mrs Gentry can you picture her talking
to you about gender or chopping your
genitals off can't you can't picture
that who's your third grade teacher
Mrs McGowan and was she interested in
chopping your genitals off no Daphne
who you don't remember your third grade
teacher completely what about your
fourth grade teacher can you give me a
name of Any teacher
Vivaldi Mrs Vivaldi and was she
interested in chopping your boobs off
she was not okay you see my point people
everyone at home like think about it
that's how far gone this whole thing has
got that we've somehow allowed this to
happen I don't know if I'm just dealing
with a bunch of right-wing Maniacs here
or what you know yeah me
anyway let's continue so uh there are
good things happening and you guys know
my feelings on polls I I think that they
are they are screwy and I try not to get
too obsessed with them but Quinnipiac
which is pretty solid Quinnipiac up in
New York they are pretty solid polling
firm uh and here's a tweet from Zach
Williams Quinnipiac has now released a
poll a New York State Governor Kathy
hochel who remembered nobody voted for
this is a woman who took over after they
deposed uh Andrew Cuomo New York State
Governor Kathy hochel is leading
Republican Lee zeldin 50 to 46 percent
ahead of the November 8 election that's
four points Four Points in blue crazy
bananas I used to live there had to get
the hell out New York that is incredible
so Lee zeldin a Republican and this is a
moderate this guy is a sane decent like
you cannot call him far right I saw
somebody had a tweet about him it's like
Lee zeldon is basically your friend's
dad who would pick you up in the in the
car and be like you can't kids have your
your uh your seat belts on let's let's
go get some ice cream that's how he
comes off this is a moderate this guy so
he responded to that and said a new poll
just released by Quinnipiac says we are
just four points down in the governor's
race we are going to win this race we
must win this race get involved today at
zeldin for New York dot coms who
freaking knows people like could it
happen everything is up in the air right
now everything is for grabs and we the
people have a chance if you're watching
this in New York
you'd go you knock on your neighbor's
door you say are you going to vote for
Kathy hochel and if they say yes you say
what's wrong with you and then you say
here's the reasons you can't vote for
this woman who demanded that people who
don't think like her leave the state and
who wants to tax you endlessly and who's
embroiled in a bunch of scandals where
people that she knows and work with got
all sorts of government contracts
sometimes for about 500 million bucks
she's not a good person and the eyebrows
are nuts I mean she's heading into
Pelosi eyebrow land and that's not good
uh the other big race of course uh in
the Senate
is in Pennsylvania and we've covered a
bit about John fetterman or as he calls
himself John Federer woman uh who's
having trouble speaking he wants to
release all the criminals he wants
eight-month abortions I mean the guy
only wears hoodies I mean it's like come
on man you know it's going to kill you
go to freaking h m you can get a jacket
for you know 25 bucks uh anyway there is
a winning message for republicans and
his opponent Dr Oz again no one in their
right mind is like Dr Oz is a far-right
racist Republican Dr Oz who Oprah used
to love I don't know that Oprah's you
know calling him these days I met Dr Oz
a couple weeks ago at an event totally
nice guy like he knew that I toured with
Jordan Peterson we chatted for a bit
like just you may not agree with him on
everything and and he may not be as as
conservative as you want him to be but
it's like this is a lot better than
fetterman well here's the here's a
winning message by Dr Oz Pennsylvania
has become Ground Zero fentanyl deaths
we're number three in the nation we have
the largest open-air drug Market in
Philadelphia you'll go for blocks and
blocks only see addicts with needles
sticking out of their bodies and we're
farming homelessness literally
Democratic policies have resulted in
something that's shameful they won't go
there I go there because I want to show
that Republicans care about everybody
and I think our party has a big enough
tent and we love people and wherever
they are in their Journey that we can
help people in addiction and that's why
we're going to win
like it ain't rocket science we would
prefer that there not be endless drug
deaths and homelessness and Carnage on
the streets there's plenty of video we
could have showed you there is plenty of
video there are there are literally he's
not making it up block after block after
Block in Philadelphia that look like
Mogadishu on a good day like it is it is
just an absolute disastrous mess of
almost like The Walking Dead of zombie
people wandering around because they are
all hopped up on drugs and it is because
it is simply because of democrat
policies uh before we get to the final
video here if you're watching on locals
right now and you're in the chat I want
the names of more third grade teachers
there's something about third grade
teachers names that sound just like
third grade teacher names just just give
me some names of third grade teachers
I'll read some off at the end and you
can also let us know if they wanted to
chop your nuts off but I just want the
names really uh anyway so what do we do
about all this how do we get beyond all
this well let's go back to the past so
that we can get back to the future and
there was a guy Martin Luther King Jr
who wanted Unity he wanted a wide tent
he wanted Americans to care about
freedom and fight for it honestly and
earnestly I think we can get back to
that
when we let it ring from every village
from every state and every city
we will be able to speed up that day
with all of God's children black men and
white men Jews and Gentiles Protestants
and Catholics will be able to join hands
and sing in the words of the old Negro
spiritual free at last free at last
thank God Almighty
just works doesn't matter how many times
you see it it just works all right a
couple comments from the Reuben report
locals committee I want some third grade
teacher names
uh EK says is she going to advocate for
killing our existing kids next since
they cost so much in diapers and baby
food that is the next logical conclusion
of the sort of death cult mentality of
the Democrats it sounds crazy but
actually they do talk about post-birth
abortions of course you're talking about
Stacy Abrams there which is you know
just abort you want some stuff you know
everybody wants to go to the mall with a
little extra cash you know go to Orange
Julius do they still have orange julius
or I feel like you're you like those
pretzels you like those buttery pretzels
Aunt Annies yeah you definitely like
those
um
um yes would they why if you're like
strapped for cash why not get rid of
your kids why not yeah I don't know if
you have to kill them but why not just
drive them to uh the local bus stop and
just be like you know not that
interested uh sorry I I want new shoes
Manolo blonics that's the type of shoe
Jimmy Choo uh talway says the Democrats
can't say they will accept the results
early because they can't whine and cry
about having the election stolen if they
if they lose that's exactly right like
that's the point and and that's also the
scary point and trust me if the
Republicans win the house and win the
Senate and get a bunch of these
gubernatorial races we are going to have
two endless years leading into the
presidential election of questioning
election results and all the stuff that
were banned and not allowed to say now
we will all be allowed to say it or
they'll be allowed to say it Matthew
says can Dave be press secretary I get
this question a lot would I be press
secretary
look if DeSantis jumps in and there is a
functioning Administration well first
off he's got Christina Pusha who is just
so spectacular I've had her on the show
if you haven't seen it she joined me at
the event we did a live event in Miami
uh she's just so wonderful that I don't
think they need me but I think there's
so there could be I don't know maybe a
little some use or Trump maybe little
some use to have me around and making
fun of the media and just throwing it
back in these people's faces and stuff
all right we got a couple names of third
grade teachers Mrs Medina Mrs
vanderworth Mrs granowitz Mrs Yoder oh I
like that one Mrs Sloan Mrs Robertson
Mrs Caputo Mrs Abrams you see they all
sound like third grade teachers names
Mrs Abrams I have to go to the bathroom
which which bathroom do you want to go
to Johnny you're a boy but I'd like you
to go to the third grade bathroom the
third grade the girls bathroom it's all
so stupid we all know it's stupid and if
we just accept that it's stupid and we
get rid of these people we'll have
everything we once had and there shall
be peace if you are not subscribed on
YouTuber Rumble it's youtube.com
reubenreportrumble.com reubenreport and
uh join us so you can play along and
tell us your teachers names at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with mayor Francis Suarez
right here in Miami we taped it live in
Wynwood at our local studio is up right
now the full thing's up ad free over at
locals and we leave you with hopefully
we're getting to the end of them so we
leave you with the squad
once upon a time there were three little
girls who went to Congress
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and each promised to fight the
establishments
but I took them away from all that and
now they work for me my name is Nancy
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you George Floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how how heartbreaking was that
all right